- I want my baby-back-baby-back-baby-back.
♫ Chili's baby back ribs
No one, not myself, no one
at Chili's, heard the piece
of music after it was
done and thought this
is going to be around for 20 years.
I thought it'd be gone after six weeks.
♫ I got my baby back ribs
- [Man] Yeah, if you
want, you can have one.
- Yeah, you know, I haven't eaten one.
Why start now?
My name is Guy Bommarito.
I'm an Advertising Creative
Director and Copywriter,
and the one responsible for the Chili's
Baby Back Ribs jingle.
Barbecue sauce.
Most everybody's grown up with jingles
and I guess the older
you are the more jingles
you remember because it
used to be, you know,
the heart and soul of the entire industry.
And so by the '90s when
this song was written,
jingles had gotten to
a point where they were
the lowest common denominator
form of advertising
and everybody avoided
them 'cause they were
typically annoying and, uh, um, unpleasant.
We did it because the
client insisted on it.
We never would have done it otherwise.
I was so embarrassed
to take the assignment
back to my creative department
that I just wrote it myself.
♫ Doo-Doo-Doo-Doo-Doo-Doo
♫ I want my baby back ribs
People would either say
that's my favorite song,
I love it, or they would
say if I hear that song
one more time I'm going
to stick a fork in my eye.
When the song first started taking off,
my biggest concern was, “I hope that's not
the only thing in my obituary.”
I hope that I do something else, you know,
that surpasses that.
Because I really don't want to be known
as the guy that did Baby Back Ribs song.